scottson portland maine hey Scott how
are you I'm doing great Dave how you
doing better than I deserve what's up
well I'm hoping you can help me out
yeah so I joined in listening for about
45 days and I was based on a
recommendation by my boss who had
listened to me talk about how much money
I had to pay for my daughter's college
and I'm stressed and I can't you know
use my credit cards and kind of
spiraling out of control so he
recommended I tune into you and I've
been doing that for 45 days I borrowed
the book I call the money makeover and
we've set up a budget and you know I'm
working on it and I'm just afraid I'm
going to make a major mistake and drain
my account to pay off the car and then
not have enough money in the account to
pay the monthly bills that are coming
because I've only estimated the budget I
just don't know how aggressive to go at
it I'm just lost and till I say oh
that's alright that's normal you're
trying something new anyway so you're
heading in the right direction because
the direction you were heading one
working so you need to change something
so that many good news you're heading in
the right way and so what is your
household income um in my way she a
total combined before taxes is 130 okay
after taxes that is rayon 80s and how
much of that do you have not counting on
your home yet we owe for a car payment
that's all it's left about $6,800 paid
off all the credit cards based on the
program here and you know I am cut them
up yet I'm also still a little nervous
to do that but I've got them in a
lockbox and that's fun well the thing is
you're heading in the right direction
you've made some progress already
do you have money in savings I've got a
thousand suicide in that emergency fund
I've got another 6,800 or so that is
left over from $10,000 inheritance that
I received you've been using the
inheritance to live on or have you been
living on our income no living on the
income why would then use that money I
used part of it for my
daughters pay about twenty thousand a
year to my daughter who's a sophomore in
college and I'm cash flowing
you know her payments over when is when
is the next payment due on that if now
do monthly so I set up a monthly plan
where I paid $2,200 a month right and
you can do that out of your insight I
think once I get this budget under
control and I you know I've stopped the
bleeding and spending money where we
don't need to spend money I think I can
but I think you can't read that yeah I'm
also wait a month okay it's nothing in
the world I think you can do it is your
wife on board oh yeah she's totally on
board come and we skipped ahead we've
been putting fifteen percent into 401ks
now for number of years yes I didn't
know any better no that was a bad thing
it's just you did that while you had all
this other debt I would stop that
temporarily until you get this car paid
off and until you get a good savings
because let's pretend the car was paid
for and you had twenty five thousand
dollars in the bank
yeah well you can start your 401k up and
you'd have plenty of wiggle room in your
budget wouldn't you yeah yeah yeah
you're heading in the right direction
three months from two now the all these
wrinkles will be ironed out if you keep
the iron on the ironing board but well
you know what happens when the irons on
the ironing board is there's heat
involved okay right and so you keep
pushing on the wrinkles and they're
going to be gone okay would you continue
to put in with a company matches so now
that Narda know okay temporarily stop
until your debt free and have your
emergency fund in place because a big
old 401k and still having a car payment
and no money saved for emergencies is
not a healthy place that's why you're
calling me you got a knot in your
stomach yeah big one yep so you'd you
know let's see if the knot goes away
when you have no payments but a house
payment and twenty five thousand dollars
in savings for emergencies no not now
right right no at that point you feeling
pretty good yeah so here's what I want
you to do I want you and your wife to go
through our class Financial Peace
University and I'm going to pay for it
okay well thank you if I give it to you
will you promise to attend the class
absolutely I looked online to fifteen
years two classes that may have already
started now but there are
that's fine just jump in with them
you'll be fine hold on I'm going to have
a kit sent to you and you jump into one
of those classes you and your wife and
and 30 days from now you're going to be
fine of course jump on every dollar and
be using every dollar calm the free
budgeting tool which helps you keep
control of the budget you're doing
better than you feel like you're doing
Scott but anytime you're earning
wrinkles out there's always heat and so
that that's a good thing that's how
that's how we get out there Incas ironed
out and you're going to be there this
time next year there's going to be a
distant memory and you're going to have
a smile on your face you're heading in
the right direction you know why most
people don't win they don't bother you
have to bother it to be intentional
never again as American Express going to
call my house and ask my wife why she
would stay with a man that won't pay his
bills